time-travel monsters and medieval guys
who say dude yeah the doctors back
Doctor Who series 9 season premiere The
Magician's apprentice now usually when I
do these things I do them spoiler free
that's frankly that's just not gonna be
the case here cuz I can't even talk
about the first five minutes of this
thing without getting into what I would
consider to be a massive spoiler and
something that I don't think anyone
should know going in they should come
into this cold so spoiler free version
opens excellently has a few up and down
moments ends on a cliffhanger that I'm
not sure that I love intrigue to see how
it ends so jumping right into spoilers
this seriously the cold opened this
episode might be the best cold open in
the history of Doctor Who it's amazing
and it's stunning and those hands coming
out of the ground and gravity we getting
them down that's awesome and that's
creepy and there's a wonderful
anachronism to the sort of world there's
biplanes with firing lasers and there's
this kid trapped and the doctor and the
doctor just has great doctor lines you
know come on tell me your name tell me
the name of the boy who's not gonna die
today and the kid says his name is
Davros and that shot that pulling in
doesn't break doesn't cut shot of the
doctors face just falling oh that's an
epic open after that things are a little
bit more up and down there's some really
good moments there's nothing that
completely turned me off but there were
a lot of things that I was kind of yeah
about I like that Missy's back and who
she was coming back I called that before
I am really liking Missy I feel like
Michelle Gomez is really embracing this
part making your own but it still feels
like the master in a lot of ways
particularly if you know the character
going back into the classic era it does
feel like the same character but it's
just it's just a fun different spin and
again being careful to reiterate that
she is crazy she is dangerous and she
will kill people for little or no reason
and that's all that's important to
emphasize I mean that that's the entire
reason that she killed Osgood last time
we saw her because otherwise she's so
fun that you just put
actually forget that she's actually
really bad news so we get that reminders
that's all works I like the sort of
banter between her and Clara I like the
way they bounce off each other I really
like the way that she works when talking
to the doctor directly
I like the doctors whole sort of thing
in the medieval setting where he comes
out with a guitar on the tank and the
guy who's standing there goes dude like
that that's awesome I'd like that and I
like that setting before because I've
seen the sort of pre cool thing the
doctors meditation so I actually really
liked that character of bohr's and
actually I'm really really irritated
that he turned out to be a Dalek shell
or whatever we call those things because
I was kind of secretly hoping he was
gonna be the new companion after Clara
leaves yes sidenote confirmed
Clara is leaving at the end of the
series finally so that that way it will
be off my shoulders everyone have to be
wondering is she finally got it she's
gonna go so maybe I'll be able to relax
and enjoy her I do like seeing Davros
you know as we know him back again I
just like how tired he looks not just
looks but how he the way he says his
lines it's a really good performance
that said I'm really kind of up and down
about the whole nature of the Davros
Doctor thing as I said I love that
cold-open I love the doctor being put in
that dilemma which they do a deliberate
call back to back to genesis of the
Daleks where the doctor asked that very
question that he then found himself in
that situation of if you knew that
someone who was a child was gonna grow
up to be the worst thing ever could you
kill them while there's still a child
and I'd like you being in that situation
what I don't think I like is the fact
that Davros remembers that and that
potentially heavily informs what he ends
up doing and then it becomes a matter of
did the doctor create Davros and that I
don't like it's not necessary it doesn't
add anything and it just kind of makes
the world feel too small that's like one
connection to many that it's just these
two kind of feeding into each other and
then it's like well nothing else matters
aside from each other and I don't like
it for the same reason that I didn't
like and listen where Clara delivered
the exact same speech to a young doctor
that the doctor then gave to a young Dan
I feel like it just it just locks too
many things in stone too early any
character's development and I want to
say it's too much fate but I don't have
a problem with fate I can deal with fate
but it late stretches my ability to deal
with that
the Daleks coming back and I wasn't sure
I'd like too much either now then the
first I like we see and then we got a
mix of different kinds of Daleks which
is something that I like but some of
them we saw looked really sixties I
don't think I really love this
cliffhanger either because even though
I'm really interested to see how this
story will play out the actual point
that they chose to sort of end this
episode on I I don't like ending at this
point either cuz for first of all what
we see the doctor prepare to do which is
to kill Davros as a child he's not gonna
do he can't do that I mean that is a
fundamental betrayal of what the doctor
is and at this point I don't believe
that it's a matter of him having to fix
or change time so that he saves Clara
and Missy Clara and Missy are not dead
I'm calling that right now
for the same reason that I called it
before which is that they vanished when
they were hit with the Dalek beams Dalek
beams do not vaporize they don't
disintegrate
they don't make people vanish they make
them do the skeleton look and then they
fall down dead there's a body left
behind there's no body here in either
case which was the same thing that
happened when Missy was supposedly
killed back at the end of last series so
whatever she did to get out of that she
did again and she did it - Clara - so as
a cliffhanger I'm not like oh because I
just I I feel like I'm ahead of this the
thing that is it's dangling in front of
me as the cliffhanger I feel like well
no I kind of already know what's gonna
have about again it doesn't mean I'm not
interested to see how it ends I'm really
curious how this story's gonna wrap up
but it's it's a good episode it's but
it's got some uneven qualities I guess
the other thing that I don't love I I
don't love that they're sort of opening
the series with this sort of who the
doctor thinks he's gonna die things like
I feel like we've seen the doctor where
he knew or believed going in that he was
gonna die I think I feel like that's
been done a few too many times in the
last couple of years hook me in on
something else
hooked me on the adventure the scope the
scales the other people
whoo-hoo he's trying to save cuz I never
believe that the doctor is going to die
but you can get me invested in the
people he's trying to save or whatever
he's trying to do there's a lot that I
do like about this this episode and the
things that I like I really like but I
feel like they're hanging key points on
aspects that I not particularly care for
so I guess that about wraps it up I
don't know if this is gonna mark these
reviews beings more spoilery than they
have in the past maybe but in any case
premiere episode of Doctor Who even
though it had both good and bad points
I'm so happy that it's back it's my
favorite show Bar None
did you see the premiere episode what
were your thoughts on it whatever they
were drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it until next time
this council is adjourned